botar eu venho aqui hoje falar de
cooperação nos centros de convenção e
como o tema hoje é ocupado chan vai
importar um pouco da minha experiência
como empreendedor e como alguém que
tenha sua empresa em quadra tamanho de
uma incubadora numa universidade em
conta a exposição eu estou aí design
industrial no porto
comecei a trabalhar por cá na alguns
projectos associados como o design
gráfico e multimídia e mais tarde seria
viajar para ampará-los onde estou aí
o design foi entregue em mídia ano
passado e tive alguns contatos com
bastantes pessoas que me ajudaram a ter
uma visão um pouco empreendedora sobre o
que seria um nome a minha vida no futuro
e é pensar como é que seriam os meus
negócios é na altura como sabe fazer
pequenos projectos ganha em inglaterra
frente associados e web design gráfico é
economias em portugal sim em trabalhar
após a troca já trabalharam as duas
empresas sindicatos e criar entre o meu
próprio negócio e foi que o incentivo ao
lado empreendedor e que o efetivo vai o
meu lado empreendedor cria duas empresas
uma em 2008 uma empresa de pesquisas
emarketer tônica fazemos três de
futebolista e mais tarde uma empresa de
placas móveis interativos
o que é isso então de incubação surgiu
nos anos 50 nos estados unidos mais
precisamente em 1959 começou num estado
de nova york e só mais tarde é que
passou pela europa em portugal só em 87
é que tivemos por 105 a céu começou a
surgir em portugal
empresas como a google ea u foram
fundadas em centros de educação
professora um pouco a importância do que
o próprio mercado então que estão em
incubadoras de empresas com uma seleção
nacional de valores dos estados unidos
diz
as incubadoras promovem o
desenvolvimento dos empreendedores
ajudantes aquecer e durante a fase
as empresas estão mais vulneráveis a
crescer e é sobreviver sobretudo existem
então três fases para para 5,5 a empresa
ficar incubada xisto o fase de pré
incubação de uma fase em que visto um
business case para avaliar a
possibilidade de uma empresa entrar no
clima com o céu é depois disso então o
processo de incubação em que é efetivado
o processo de passagem para 1 101 céu
seja um processo físico em que uma
empresa fica incubada no local
eu não tenho acesso a uma série de
situações que vão expandir e melhorar o
seu negócio e depois existe uma fase de
pós em comoção
esta pausa incubação existe mais para
servir somente em prol dos projetos
empresas que acabam sendo incubação e
servem de inspiração para outros outras
empresas e que também possam participar
ainda eventos tecnológicos em eventos e
empreendorismo associados ainda ao
centro em que você os principais tipos
de cinco valores que existem são
encorajadoras para o desenvolvimento da
economia local que são as mães mas o
usuais foi vigorosa em conta isso
necessitaria existe bastante temos até
uma máquina deve estar quitada pelo
porto enquanto outras ligadas ao centro
empresarial como existem imensos
empresariais que utilizam o espaço para
distribuir em comoção para empresas e
também em incubadoras tempos e dos
privados
muitas empresas criam por vezes um
centro de incubação
parece tratar de algumas idéias e
projetos aí às vezes pequenas e que a
partir daí desenvolvem para bons museus
negócio e que ajudam a impulsionar uma
série de negócios sobre esta mesma
empresa em portugal já temos mais de 35
dólares
isto mostra que algo que foi começou
aposta começou em nos anos 80 evoluiu
bastante e sentimos que é algo que ajuda
é o crescimento econômico em portugal
por isso já tem vindo a crescer
exponencialmente nos últimos anos
queria falar com a mãe do colchão as
fantasias de trás tem que você é um
espaço de trabalho onde podemos própria
empresa tem um local para trabalhar lá
se foi tamanho que trabalhem com o
working acesso à internet gratuito
a saúde dos animais também são recorde e
é fácil am sasha salas de reuniões
mesmo com outras empresas e tentem
explorar o ambiente de partilha que
cento dentro não sei que você é
depois também temos como esse é um fator
muito importante mas o legado
competitiva por muitas empresas no
início o fator de pagar um facto pode
ter que pagar uma renda do escritório é
algo que é decisiva e que o projeto não
havendo uma situação econômica favorável
é algo complicado gerir e esta massa da
competitiva que o centro tem concentrava
em é uma vantagem muito grande pra
empresa estou a começar os opõe da
controladoria gestão que também algo pra
projeto numa fase embrionária é difícil
às vezes e conseguido ter um melhor
apoio para esta conta é olhado estão a
informação sobre o fundo de
financiamento que nem sempre são
possíveis e às vezes é difícil porque
não conseguimos isso em um só local e
perceber todos os pontos que existem
para a nossa empresa e todos os tipos de
financiamento que existem neste momento
pois também existe o ecossistema
empreendedor que se vive criança respira
dentro do dossiê que você não
conseguimos perceber que é o único que
conseguimos partilhar nossas idéias com
outras pessoas
mesmo num mar de um coffee break ou
quando houve alguns eventos realizados
pela incubadora conseguimos perceber que
é fácil sentir este ecossistema que nos
ajuda a seleção de och e ter esse
espírito empreendedor e por último
também atividades networking night work
que no caso da cinex ou uma um evento
neste presente em 2012 março de 2012 e
que foi preponderante para tomar a
decisão de passar para uma empresa que
na altura tinha uma sede própria
não sei nem presentão para um certo que
você anda universidade e foi foi nesta
nesta neste evento no qual eu senti que
tanta gente expor seus projetos e
partilhavam cirurgias de coração é um
entre as empresas que só faria sentido
criar uma empresa pouco tempo se passar
lá presente que conseguem foi das
melhores já que eu tinha na minha vida
vanda 52 jovens na universidade é o que
temos hoje em dia é um um dia de
recuperação e como que virá
isto porque o as duas não estão
licenciadas a gente existe uma simbiose
entre o que é cooperação podemos culpar
a entre várias empresas
apesar da competitividade que existe
alguma com cuidado frost e às vezes é
difícil porque a mentalidade não ajuda
quando não queremos mostrar ao nosso
vizinho que faz o mesmo cross
a nossa ideia isso pra mim acho que
transportavam as drogas
acho que só valoriza o nosso negócio e
valorizamos também nossos outros tentam
recuperar a cobrança oito competidores é
nosso espaço que lhe fizemos já em meus
projetos com outras empresas também com
balas que essas novas projetos de
aplicações para redes sociais e foi algo
que foi bastante interessante perceber
como conseguimos utilizar as cirurgias e
mesmo a melhor parte de cada uma das
empresas para criar projetos melhores e
valorizar os conjuntos projetos têm o
prazo de um ano é de um amigo meu que já
se teve surpresa enquanto você precisa
nem falar né não sei que você não
danificará católica neste momento está
em um cão começou por apostar em qual
universidade e eu disse que o momento é
com o coração dele tem valor foi
essencial e que garantiu vocês empresas
complementares ea investigação ea
própria universidade
a soja eo possível que só faria sentido
está está no estado em cuba por
conseguiria ter acesso a outras outras
possibilidades que não conseguiria outra
forma
paulo que vai da cooperação para para
intervenções é um vício também uma
ligação muito próxima da al-105 você é
um cluster de indústrias criativas e
como existem cá no porto existem em
portugal isto é muito importante porque
uma chuva de forma que conseguimos
potenciar os nossos negócios e passaram
já os gaúchos próprio mercado
internacional nem sempre é fácil nem
sempre percebemos qual é o melhor
caminho e não ser que você não temos um
melhor apoio para conseguirmos
participar e ser ativos dentro das
condições dos coletivos por conseguinte
policial nosso negócio e passar por uma
fase internacional
qual a importância das incubadoras
uma economia que cresce o emprego é como
existe este 65 moção em que não é
preciso muito para começar a empresa e
podemos facilmente a partir de uma idéia
legal assim perceber pra lá vão e esse é
um dos responsáveis por cento em
dezembro o céu se ela tem algum grau não
conseguimos facilmente gerar então uma o
crescimento econômico porque estamos a
criar empregos porque estamos a dar
emprego a jovens que têm a sua ideia de
negócio e querem passar por uma casa
alguma forma
preciso só posso valorizar o crescimento
econômico e por último quero falar de
algo pra ninguém mas é importante que é
uma infox.ru isto quer dizer o que é que
acha difícil se escolhemos um caminho um
museu um lugar fácil mantermos nessa
mudança legal se porque é fácil abrimos
o leque e começarmos por um serviço e
depois de fazer imensos
eu acho que é importante porque está a
começar um negócio perceber qual é nossa
nós precisamos é um problemas muito
longe daquela área e nos focarmos só
naquilo que somos muito bons e tentaram
dispersar seja com ser competitivos que
está a dar o melhor de nós aquilo que
nós áreas precisamos é não porque haja
espaço para tanta gente e depois desse
negócio foi bom e queremos trabalhar
mais podemos abrir uma nova empresa mas
como cowboy mantermos o foco naquilo que
é a nossa especialização é isto
obrigado